we're here with max Schaffer CEO of
extra games and we're gonna be talking
all about torchlight 3 max thanks for
thanks for joining us today happy to be
here thanks so it feels like from the
brief time I've played torchlight 3
you're going very much back to the roots
of what made torchlight such a such a
success yeah you know as as people may
or may not know we began the project
with it being a little bit more to the
MMO side of things we made the switch
because we found that we were not
designing systems that were true to the
torchlight franchise and we were trying
to make long gaming loops that let
themselves to monetization for a
free-to-play title you know it just
didn't feel right
the game was telling us that it wanted
to be more like the original torch
lights and so we made a pivot and we
renamed it torchlight 3 from torchlight
frontiers because it is a more spiritual
successor to the previous ones and we
kept all the good parts though we kept
all the fun stuff like it is it is a
shared world you know see if there are
shared towns their shared Forks you will
see other players running around you can
party up with anybody so we kept all the
good parts and then dips to all the
parts that make the players weren't
really liking we weren't really having
fun designing for and just concentrated
on making it a rollicking good time you
know and that drives everything at this
point that just works better for us
what's it hard kind of pivoting from all
the work he'd put in to frontiers to
remake it is into torchlight 3 yeah I
mean there were parts of it that were
hard because things had to be rebalanced
and things that were like again designed
to be you know worked on over months it
had to be tightened up you know just to
make them funner there's a lot of
rebalancing to do we actually did a
pretty good job of designing the game in
a modular way from the beginning that
can be reconfigured and reorganized
fairly easily but the biggest thing is
that is it kind of just freed us up
again to concentrate on what's fun and
what's cool in the game and that's in a
way made it easier to design form and I
mean torchlight a series has never
really been marred in the traditional a
RPG sort of cliches especially when it
comes to your classes so how have you
gone about making the very weird ones in
torchlight 3 well yeah that's one of my
favorite parts of the game is that is
the class
actually so our basic theory with
character classes always is that it
should not be a cliche it shouldn't be
right down Main Street of what you think
about a class should be however it
should be something that you kind of
intuitively understand what they do when
you see it this time you know we took
some risks we made our first character
class that is fully robotic you know and
the fear on that one was what are people
going to be able to identify and
emotionally connect with with something
that's you know a robot and I think that
we realized pretty quickly that in some
ways are the forged class which is our
robotic mind is is the most human of any
of them you know all the others have
some stick where they you know they have
magic and all this stuff but that the
Forge just wants to be loved and it was
it was something that that we just ran
with and have almost the most fun with
and of course another the character
classes the rail master he is loosely
based on the engineer class from the
previous torch lights and the lore of
the engineer class was they worked on
the railroads out in the wilderness and
this time we've said let's really push
that and actually have him have a train
that he uses with them that's another
one where it's like is this really gonna
be a thing or are we getting ourselves
into a deep hole here by trying this but
it's really fun it adds a whole new kind
of strategic element to it you know you
have to care where your train is it's
kind of part of your character and it
has some of the most fun gameplay
dynamics in my opinion but yeah we
always try to aim kind of in the gas and
and come up with something new for
character classes is that something you
want to kind of build upon on the life
of torchlight 3 will you be introducing
more classes as the as the game goes
through its life certainly it's in the
drawing boards we have other ideas for
classes and and it's something we really
really hope to do we we don't have set
plans yet on what form the the
additional building in the world will
take I mean obviously we're gonna
trickle in stuff and work on patches and
get stuff going but we haven't really
nailed down yet whether we'll do
expansions or sequels or what or what
but it we actually have
new character classes on the drawing
board in progress to make and they're
pretty cool also so yes the answer is
yes and you've kind of taken another
look at what it means to have legendary
items in a RPG right and it's it feels
like you're giving a longer lifespan to
getting legendary items after you know
obviously it takes so long to grind for
these things sometimes or it's a stroke
of luck
it's always heartbreaking to give them
up can you talk a little bit about the
legendarium that you've introduced yes
so we've made these wonderful legendary
enemies and they're all your hand
crafted they don't just pick from the
pool of a-sixes and power-ups and stuff
they're really hand crafted and have
some very unique abilities and we
realized that for a while that you know
you get them not just at the endgame you
know these are things that we sprinkled
throughout the game it was it was just
kind of heartbreaking to give them up
you know and you've leveled out of their
range and they're no longer the best
thing in the world but they still have
souls one or two really cool abilities
on them so we created the legendarium
and what that lets you do is break down
your your legendary item and keep one of
those affixes and and and and it becomes
basically like a skill that would be in
a skill tree for you but you can use
that for your character build so you
never really give up the cool stuff that
you find in your legendary items and it
can really become part of the deep
character build our character builds are
much deeper than they are at first
glance if you simply look at the
character the skill tree if it's fairly
normal you know and and it looks like
okay well that's just a skill tree but
that's just part of what makes your
character build you know there's that
your pets have skills you get
legendarium skills and you also collect
these and craft these relic weapons or
they're not really weapons there's relic
items and those have their own skill
tree and so you pick which witch weapon
or which item goes with your character
and you know the combination of all but
just gives you a almost infinite amount
of builds that you can make and we found
that it's actually deeper than just
making a bigger skill tree and this was
something you've added quite late into
the closed beta phase right and but what
have you learned from it being in closed
beta 4 is only a few short months but
why are you kind of taken away from it
well we've only been in closed beta for
a few short months that's kind of a
funny story actually but prior to that
we were in a closed alpha and we've been
in that for you know about a year and a
half at least and all the time during
that we've been listening to what the
players have said and we've we've made a
lot of pivots in the game we've
discussed one of them earlier and going
from a free-to-play MMO to a premium
title and the player feedback is is
super essential on a game like this
because you know we're busy all day
making stuff and Tooting things and
doing this and that and we can't really
tell you if if with this particular
character the level grind between 40 and
60 is too grindy or not you know we just
don't have time to be investing that but
our players do and and so we're able to
use that and use all their input to make
all this new stuff and you know we are
we are just very recently now in early
access as well and we're going to
continue to use this time to listen to
the players and you've really hone it
into the best game that could possible
people we could not do it without having
the game live and having players playing
it and you know giving us real-world
feedback because you know we sit at our
computers all day and you get kind of
tunnel vision and and sometimes you lose
perspective a little bit and it's great
to have that reality check from the
players so what's been the biggest
change that's come into the game that's
come from the players it by far the
biggest is the switch in business model
and that really changed the way the game
is played it changed the the layout and
the progression and get it let us
tighten up the system it's an a RPG and
ARPGs are tough to put into that really
long game loop format where you're
you're monetizing things and the guys
that path of Exile did a great job at
doing that
but it just wasn't working for our for
our world you know we're a little bit
more lighthearted to begin with it's a
little bit more about instant
gratification
it's it's a game we want you to be able
to play without having to invest your
life in it
you know we've found that a lot of our
players play all the damn time but a lot
of players also just like to play a half
an hour and
evening and have that be a meaningful
session and not just a trivial part of
the games you know journey and so so
that was the biggest one lots and lots
and lots of tuning just little details
all over the place like the the
particulars of how the difficulty
settings work the legendarium came out
of of that because people were like I am
bummed out because I'm having to get rid
of all these cool looking legendary
items and so yeah I mean it's it's
everything from like our whole business
model down to little tiny details and
it's something we go over everyday you
know it's something that affects what
we're working on every single day and in
addition to this bug fixes you know they
also report hey it crash when I did this
so they're also like the world's
greatest a few a staff so ARPGs
traditionally have quite a long tail to
them have you got any plans that you can
speak of yeah how you're going to
support the game long term we have a
really really cool end game feature
that's not quite in yet it's going to be
going in very very soon that I can't
speak about yet but it is is it's it's a
really fun new take on how to do an end
game prior and this also came a little
bit from feedback from our players but
you know going into this we had what we
called the map-works which was basically
just a way to run dubs and do dungeon
runs based on map Scrolls that we'd give
you and you could just do that and keep
leveling up your character and it works
for people who would just love to you
know find the next cool item and keep
leveling up but it was just a little bit
dry and not quite you know worthy of
what you would call an endgame and so
what we've come up with is an
alternative that again is coming up very
very soon that just makes it super fun
cool challenging and gave it gives you
different choices and I think people
will really like it but I can't say too
much of it I'll get in trouble from our
our marketing department there was
obviously a lot of work put into you
when the game was known as frontiers is
the idea of kind of that free to play
game with MMORPG sort of elements some
think that you still want to explore or
revisit down the line well I think we
were able to keep the parts that we
really
woman to have intact it's just with the
different business model so we have
always wanted to have like a shared town
like we in I was involved with the
diablos way back in the day and even
back into the Diablo 2 days our goal was
to have a shared town and make it feel
like you're in a real world and not just
like you're logging in with the
character and maybe playing with a
couple friends and a shared town is kind
of the beginning of making it really
feel like a community and a couple of
the other things that that we've kept
our shared forts so we've got a really
cool twist on player housing where you
your whole account gets a fort so all of
your characters share one four and this
is something that like other player
housing it's a place to store stuff to
have your trophies and decorate and do
all that cool stuff but it has much more
profound gameplay implications for
example you can make things in your fort
and build them that give your whole
account a boost like you can make it you
can plant a luck tree and by feeding the
luck tree magic items over time you grow
your luxury and your luxury gives all of
your characters a slight magic vine
bonus and you can make an enchanting
table and unlock recipes and the cool
thing about this that is MMO like is
that we've put people sports out into
the world sort of randomly so you'll
encounter other people's sports as you
as you wander across the world and if
they have a luck tree you can use their
luck tree like a shrine so if I just
donate a magic item to their luxury I
will get like a five-minute magic vine
bonus I can use their enchanting table
and use all the the recipes that they've
unlocked to my own items so if it's it's
something that really kind of in
franchises you in the world and makes
you feel like what I'm building is
impacting other players experience in
the world and so that's that that was
one of the cool things that was that we
had designed for the MMO that we were
able to keep in this model so I feel
like we were able to to like check all
the boxes that we really wanted to hit
just without having to make it a
free-to-play MMO
is that your golden retriever in the
background that was my lab labrador
retriever yes she is an absolute cream
puff but she fantasizes about defending
the realm for sure
is that why you can get pet dogs of in
the game as well any modelled after her
yeah actually it's it's it's somewhere
between a lab and a golden retriever in
the game but it looks a lot like my dog
so that's what's not believin if you can
pick from a few pets when you make a
character bets another thing you've that
we've kind of kept from the MMO side of
it is you can find and collect pets out
in the world by completing quests and
put a little pets table in your fort so
that you can collect them all there and
they very often will come up come with a
new skill and that you can apply to any
of your patch so the skills are sort of
MIT mix and match and so like the
collection of pets is another really
cool thing that we kept from the MMO
days and so you can just have a huge
stable of pets and pick whichever one
you want
of course I tend to stick with the dog
for obvious reasons I know this is
probably quite long term but since torch
like to was so well-received when you
made a switch port is that going to
something you aim for down the line with
torchlight 3
well we're for sure doing Xbox and
Playstation and those versions are
coming along very very well we're
looking at switch and whatever else
comes down the line I think it would be
really cool on the switch it is the most
most challenging platform to to port to
just based on the you know the fidelity
of all the graphics and everything but
we're giving it a good college try I
can't say we're doing it yet because I
don't want to say anything that turns
out to not be true but works where you
know we're looking that way because I
think it would be pretty cool well thank
you so much for joining us just quickly
once one more question are you ready to
give a date when people can get their
hands on the game yet it's the only data
I can give you is this year it's for
sure coming out this we're going to take
the early access period to you know get
people's feedback and make the necessary
changes again to make it as good as we
can I think that you probably are aware
that game developers are notoriously bad
at predicting exactly when they will be
finished and we were going by that
criteria you know we're not
to ship it until it's finished and so
any date I give you will just make me
look stupid in a few months
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk to us and anyone out there who
wants to see more on torchlight three
well make sure you stay tuned it's a
game spot
[Music]
you